if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful you feel a love
for life you feel a joy for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated
in by the universe into wealth you will
be initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of that now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
manifest and use vision boards enjoy
rule number two is think positive with
bruce lipton if i have a picture of fear
in my mind i'm afraid of something
my brain translates fear with different
chemicals stress hormones cortisol
norepinephrine
factors that affect immune system that
are called cytokines or histamine
so basically in a state of conscious
fear the brain releases chemistry that
complements fear that chemistry goes
into the body's blood and that changes
the behavior and the genetics of the
person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts
and people say oh that positive thinking
doesn't really work but that's not true
the best example of positive thinking in
a scientific study is called placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
this new pill and it's the brand new
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill
so then you're left with
so what made me well it's not the sugar
pill it was the positive belief in that
sugar pill and how it's going to help
your life so that's called placebo
positive thinking positive result
unfortunately most people don't
recognize a more important point
negative thinking is equally powerful
but it works in the opposite direction
so it turns out for example
less than 10 of cancer is even connected
to a family lineage
90 of cancer just comes out of the blue
so to speak but the reality is no it's a
result of stress and negative thinking
so it's important point positive
thinking negative thinking equally
powerful because that's the level of
consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics
i just want to add a very important
point to this quantum physics is the
most valid science on this planet there
is no science that has been tested more
and verified more i guess so what's the
relevance because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of our lives rule
number three create a vision board with
john assaraf whenever i want to create
anything whether it's my physical body a
home a car a trip
there's a big part of our brain called
the occipital lobe back of our brain
even when light comes in through our
eyes right cells in the back of our
brain activate and an image pops up in
our brain
and that image that pops up into our
brain is connected to the motivational
center and the thinking center part of
our brain
so if a negative image pops up we reduce
our motivation and we don't take action
and then we reinforce that pattern but
let's say i have a an image of something
that i really want something that
inspires me that as soon as i pop up
that image in my brain i actually
release dopamine
okay uh the reward neurochemical in my
brain that actually creates motivation
that's actually tied to what i call as
the einstein part of the part of the
brain that can actually help you figure
out how to achieve that thing
and so i create
images of what is it that i want to
create for health wealth relations
career business charity fun and
experiences so that i can activate the
reward circuits in my brain the
motivational circuits in my brain the
thinking centers of my brain to help me
figure out how to achieve it but the
other purpose of a vision board is to
give your brain the instruction of this
is the stuff that's important to me that
i want to create do be have or give
right so you know we all have you know
50 000 thoughts a day we all have so
much on the social media whether it's
facebook or instagram or youtube or
clubhouse or whatever all the different
you know stations and channels are the
people that want to get gather our
attention well why don't we become
better at focusing our attention on what
we want to trade our life for
right because when somebody is pulling
us to look at their stuff
like
well
we're part of their goals and dreams and
and their vision versus me being focused
on what is it that i want to trade my
life for and instructing my brain help
me find ways to trade my life for these
things
and that's how to use your brain
properly
um versus your brain using you
because it may not have you know been
conditioned properly with the right
beliefs and focus and awareness and
habits
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four prime your
imagination with bob proctor most people
use their imagination they use it the
wrong way they imagine
what won't work imagine something bad
happening
um
what should we imagine more often every
day we should imagine you should
see yourself where you want to be
you got to live there
there's a great book
you may be familiar with stella adler's
book the art of acting
oh gosh you've got to get it stella
adler was a great acting teacher she was
a method acting teacher she did she
studied understands laski the the
russian acting teacher that originated
method acting
marlon brando wrote the forward in her
book he was the first
method actor to reach super stardom okay
and
he wrote the forward in her book now
still adler never actually wrote a book
a man named
kissel
took all of her teaching all her lessons
for teaching and she put them into or he
put them into a book so when you read
her book you're going to reacting
classes
and
like shakespeare said we're all actors
you know the world's the stage when
that's true
well when you reach a goal you're going
to act like you're already there
it's already happened intellectually the
second you think about it
it's already happened emotionally when
you're emotionally involved with it so
it's only a period of time until it
manifests in physical form
but because it's not in physical form we
act like them got it yet yeah well so
that's why most people stay stuck
because they're acting like they haven't
got it yet
or
if i can't act like that lewis would see
that i haven't got that result he'll
he'll think i'm phony
i gotta quit worrying about what lewis
thinks and start concentrating on what
bob thinks
and so
you see yourself your imagination you
got to be that person
gertie said that great philosopher he
said before you can do something
universe must be something so you've got
to be it intellectually you've got to be
it emotionally that's sake solomon says
as a person things in their heart the
emotional mind
well it's only a period of time then to
manifest physically that's one of the
first laws of the universe is the
perpetual transmutation of energy energy
is moving into form
always
to form moving into forms through form
back into form again
so
we cause it all to happen the way we
think
[Music]
and the way we stay locked into ideas
you
know how should people be uh developing
their imagination on a daily basis
in a positive way well i think they
should take time to image what they want
i have a business partner um sandy
gallagher who's a brilliant woman
and she rides horses
uh gated horses
and she's in kentucky right now in
big
term
shows there she images herself as a
world champion
every day
she takes the time and she sees herself
as a world champion
she sees herself getting the roses
getting the whole thing
and that's where you should do it
i think you build the image of what you
want
i mean you obviously imaged this
studio before you ever built it right i
mean everything you see here was part of
the image in your mind but everything
you create you create twice
what's in here what's out here
you know
so you never get an original painting
you always get a duplicate
the pictures in here wow
so we have to see yourself with what we
want here
now we've got enormous
deterrent
in our paradigm we're conditioned
genetically and environmentally
and that conditioning is controlling
most people's lives that's why brilliant
people are broke
brilliant people are unhappy brilliant
people never really accomplish very much
they're absolutely brilliant
but their paradigm is controlling them
it's all about intellect
they're smart people
but like
you got to consider where we come from
a little particle of energy from a
little particle of energy from dad comes
swimming
that's the nucleus of us
then that goes on for 280 days
attracting more energy until
you
make your debut on the planet and then
you're programmed environmentally by
your environment so everything that's
going on is going right into your
subconscious mind so you come out you're
programmed genetically
we've got we don't know how far it goes
back four or five generations possibly
like when i was a young man i had red
hair
my mother didn't have red hair my dad
didn't have red hair i got a brother and
sister and they don't have red hair
because you think well
but my mother's father and all his
brothers had red hair
so sometimes it jumps a generation
that's why we look like our relatives
it's genetic conditioning
and then there's environmental
conditioning
we know almost all welfare recipients
are fourth fifth generation welfare
recipients
so this is passed down in generation to
generation
now unfortunately we're all or
fortunately we're all exactly the same
we got exactly the same potential our
spiritual dna is perfect rule number
five recondition your mind with greg
braden i think one of the things
that we're beginning to understand we we
have been conditioned
for a couple of generations now to see
the human body is a flawed organism
carbon based life
in general and the human body
specifically is somehow flawed
and
because it is flawed that we need to
build things outside of us
that will help us to become the best
versions of ourselves to become the
achieve our greatest potentials whether
it's athletics or whether it's
mental or emotional capabilities all of
these things
so this is the path
that uh that technology is following
very very quickly and what we're seeing
is that the technology has advanced
faster than the morality
of how we apply it in our lives i'll
just give you a perfect example what i
mean by that
a couple of years ago uh scientific
papers began describing
the ability to edit
the dna
uh of an an of a fetus inside the womb
of a living woman just the way you would
edit
a
a
document in a word processor on the
computer so on the word processor you
can you can add or delete words you can
highlight the entire paragraph
cut it paste it somewhere else
we now have editors where the the genes
come up on the computer screen and you
can highlight and delete and merge and
remove and rearrange genes in the dna of
a living organism to optimize and
perfect
that organism
while it's still in the womb before it's
ever born
and the question is
whose idea
of what is optimum
do we begin to use to do something like
that well well this was all theory
they were doing it in the lab until
2018.
in 2018 there's a chinese scientist that
very proudly said holding the baby in
his arms here are our first gene edited
human babies
he had done
in real life
what had been done in the laboratory in
theory and in tests and the scientific
community came down on him like a ton of
bricks
because they said wait a minute
just because we can
doesn't mean that we should and we see
this time and time again
with technology where the technology
advances just because we can implant
a computer chip into the human brain
that connects us with a hard drive of
our computer with no wires
no keyboards
and allows us to download information
does that mean that we should and we
cannot answer those things danica until
we begin
to understand who we are so these
discover this is the way science works
the discoveries are pushing science to
understand who we are and what they are
discovering is a mind blower
because what they're i'll just say it
and then
we can unpack it
what they're discovering
i'm going to say it like this
we have yet
to
discover any technology
built outside of the human body that
does not mimic what we already do in the
cells
and the neurons and the organs of our
body except we do it better
we are what is called a soft
technology so rather than thinking of a
hard computer chip in wires and
chemicals
we're talking about neurons
and
and fluids ion potentials moving across
the membranes of cell walls and
crystalline bone structure
and
when we begin to understand what that
means
and the ability our innate ability to
self-regulate
this technology that's the mind blower
because what it says
is that yeah we we can do these things
in the technology but the technology
maybe is reminding us
of who we are
to push us in that evolutionary
direction and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is do positive affirmations with louise
hay to begin with you start by
doing what we call doing affirmations
and that is making positive statements
about your life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights and the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life they can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a you know just saying
it what i like people to do is to stand
in front of a mirror and do their
affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting and accepting yourself or
noticing that you reject yourself when
you're saying something positive about
yourself
so that would be a very
beginning way to start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and i know this
sounds far fetched but it's amazing how
it works
if you do a good general positive
statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you may be plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait for two days and then dig in
the earth and say what's happening
what's happening you expect that thing
to grow because you know there's a law
and a process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil and it has the right amount
of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night
what you believe about yourself is the
only thing that matters at the end of
the day no matter how much outside
affirmations you get or other people
telling you that you're amazing if you
don't believe in your heart that you are
amazing it won't none of that will last
like you've ever gone to an event or you
ever made a video or created something
or you're hanging out with a friend and
they tell you how amazing you are and
that feels good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades
but that stuff doesn't last you don't
have somebody being a cheerleader for
you every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting
your value as a human being
from other people when they tell you
that you're amazing
you're never going to love your life
you're never going to love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
i think for me it's this is why i
believe that lack of belief is the
world's number one problem
you know i can go and meet somebody and
feel them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they
they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines and systems and schedules to
slowly shift
your belief in yourself forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough
i just think it's great to be your own
worst critic
i think it's great i think honestly i
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things
we're very hard on ourselves but because
there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like i'm sitting here in a parking lot
these you know those i guess it's kind
of blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we we can post all these great
things on instagram or wherever and make
it look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck
hate their own lives they are barely
hanging on so how do we get through it
well
yes we can be harder on ourselves
but we need to balance that with more
self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great
what you're proud of what you're
grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you
love yourself more
that actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself more you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because
it's not going to push you over the edge
because you're not tying your self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of i'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when i go to events
a youtube event for example if i'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or youtube related
i'm going in thinking
i'm kick ass
and
because i feel that i don't need to say
that
like a lot of times
we feel like we need to say that because
it's it's
masking and insecurity
right it's like those people who uh
we've seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even jay-z like early jay-z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like he doesn't care
you know this is walking on a t-shirt
and some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so
self-confident now that it doesn't
matter now it's actually expression
instead of masculine insecurity most of
us are just masking insecurities instead
of actually being self-confident and so
when i'm going to an event if i'm
talking about youtube i'm walking in
feeling amazing
and i don't need to
i don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and
it's actually the opposite i can go up
and say hey where do i suck
it's my favorite question ask
why do i suck where do i suck can you
point it out if i can find one person to
tell me where i suck at something how my
videos suck my thumbnails suck
do i don't believe that they suck
right
i think they're amazing
but because i think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how i think
it could be better
and so i think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that i do is i put music on
and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs if
they came on you would have to you would
have to move
right it doesn't mean that you're up and
like dancing through the whole house
going crazy in your underwear first
thing in the morning but something that
even if it's just making your head bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head bob
and you'd probably be singing
maybe not out loud but singing under
your breath i'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're
singing out lyrics
that are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact so be
intentional with music that you put on
every day first start your day with
music it's the fastest way to change
your state to go from
feeling low and tired and just
what day is it what am i doing i wake up
every day like what day is it what am i
doing today yeah it's
but i demand excellence and that that
starts with music because i don't have i
don't want to spend a lot of time trying
to get into the right state of mind i
can command it whenever i want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to
the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing i'll do is i'll take
the dogs out and then i'll go for
what i call a believe walk and it's
probably the most important part of my
morning routine is i go for a believe
walk
and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and
i'll go for a walk by myself
with 20 pounds on my back i'll go
wrecking
uh i'll walk to
tim hortons usually get a coffee
you know this cost two bucks to
something
so
i only had
you know what's the what's the best
money i spend every year well it's the
700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and i'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and i'm thinking about what i
want to accomplish today and the lives
that i want to serve and the people i
want to help and and what i'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone
all the dms and the emails and the texts
and the missed calls and all it's all
other people's agenda for your time that
that is not an intentional life we wake
up like an accident and start falling
into what other people want us to do
today that's not what you need to do and
you need to protect your time
so the morning
having a believe walk for me if you want
to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too i don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar
most of my meetings would be 11 first
meeting would be 11 movement makers and
brand lytics i'll start at 10 30
and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
i want to do and so if i want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes i can do that because i'm
thinking because i'm brainstorming
because i'm i'm
going through an idea i treat that as
walking meditation
um if you like to meditate meditate that
means it's the same thing i just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much i like something a little more
active so i go for my belief locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to
think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today are you happy
with what you've done today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation
and somebody else's
words of affirmation for us to
feel worthy
and flip it to say i am worthy i am
amazing
i can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things
you know so many people think that money
is the most important thing in the world
if they don't have money they would just
die
but that's not true
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life and and
and live here air your air your breath
your breath is the most important thing
that you have the most precious thing if
you didn't take another breath you
wouldn't last three minutes and you'd
never get out of this room and yet we
absolutely take for granted
that our next breath is there look at us
we're all in this room breathing and i'm
not saying don't breathe there's not
enough for me
we assume that it's there
and when we exhale we don't think about
where's my next breath coming from
now
if the power that created us
has given us enough breath to last for
as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the other
things will take care of themselves
see life is here for us life is here to
support us to take care of us to be here
for us the entire planet
has been put here for us to play with
we have everything that we shall ever
need it's already here only we have to
know it and we have to trust it and we
have to acknowledge it
do you realize that there is more food
on this planet than people could
possibly eat
there's an incredible amount of food yes
it is true that there are people
starving
but the food is here
there is more money on this planet than
we know how to count
the money is here
now there are lots of people who are
very broke but the money is here
there are billions of people on this
planet
and yet you will have people tell you
that they're lonely
it has nothing to do with not being
people
it's what we're doing with our heads
everything is here for us for every dis
ease on this planet there is a plant
that will cure it
everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life
and acknowledge the beauty and
magnificence of our own being the more
we find everything we need it just pops
up
well the simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are accepted and
brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy to accept but once you
accept it then you can start
deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among
all the people or all the people that
are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes to begin with you start
by doing what we call doing affirmations
and that is making positive statements
about your life
that
are positive
and you do them deliberately you might
do them in the morning you might do them
at noon you might do them at night uh
you might do them you know
twice a day or whatever but you do this
and you let this become a habit
and as you start to do them
things will begin to change maybe on a
very small level i call it getting the
green lights from the parking places i
mean they're not huge things in your
life it can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry
doing an affirmation is either writing
it down writing it on the wall or the
mirror or using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do is to stand in front of a
mirror and do their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting
and accepting yourself
or noticing that you reject yourself
when you're saying something positive
about yourself
so that would be a very beginning way to
start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and this is
a big one and it's hard for lots of
people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them but if you can start your day
saying that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say and
everything you think and saying okay you
can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you and i know this
sounds far fetched but it's amazing how
it works
if you do a good general
positive statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that
how to bring that about in your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations is like planting a seed in
the ground it's not necessarily true at
the moment but it is something you want
to have be true
so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow and you
don't wait two days and then dig in the
earth and say what's happening what's
happening you expect that thing to grow
because you know there's a law and a
process and the seed will grow if it is
in the right soil and it has the right
amount of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day
doing something every morning when you
wake up that's a really good time and
another good time is when you go to
sleep at night and and gratitude works a
lot
i think that everything you think and
everything you speak goes out from you
into the universe and comes back to you
multiplied uh it's almost as though the
universe is listening to everything you
say and everything you think and saying
oh that's what they want
but most of the time we are talking very
negatively about ourselves we talk about
how awful we are we're not good enough
we can't get this we can't get that how
can the universe bring you anything good
if that's the way you're talking
attitude works a lot
uh if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful for
what the good is in your life the more
good you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know somebody
gives you a present
or gives me a present and i say oh my
god i hate that color and it doesn't fit
and you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude well the simple
part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are
accepted and brought back to us as
experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
[Music]
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among
all the people or all the people that
are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes i know that you've heard
me say many times or you've read or
listened on the tapes that loving
yourself
is the most powerful thing we can do
then everything flows
everything flows beautifully i'm not
talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible
magnificent being that we are
you know little babies know how to love
themselves you were born in pure love
all of you there's not one little baby
alive i that i know of that ever
criticizes its body or ever says my hips
are too big have you ever heard a baby
say that
[Applause]
they're just thrilled and delighted that
they have a body
they rejoice in it and they love
themselves they love their toes they
love everything about themselves they
absolutely adore
they
express their feelings you know when a
baby is happy you know it when a baby is
angry the whole neighborhood knows it
they're never scared to let people know
how they feel they live in the moment
and they're filled with courage
and they're wonderful and we were all
like that
got to remember that you were filled
with courage and you were full of love
and you adored yourself when you were
very little after they're done doing
their work they can go and tap on those
issues so sort of combine both together
you do the mirror work it brings up the
things that are bubbling or maybe you
can even tap in front of the mirror
maybe that'll be the next innovation and
tap and say affirmations in front of the
mirror you know yes
yes so do you want to do a little
tapping sure you know for for the for
the crowd so
i know we did a little there you had a
little neck pain the last couple days so
we did some tapping but we could always
do a little more yeah
so how how deep do you want to go
well how do you do you want to take me
so let's for for people who weren't with
us private last couple sessions let's
talk about the neck pain and what was
going on and
um and our conversation it started as
some spasms yes it started as some
spasms that wouldn't go away okay and i
was feeling tremendous pressure back
here and down my neck
and uh i realized that this went back to
a time when i was five years old and
my stepfather used to hold my head under
water and he had his thumb in that
particular place
and
my thought was for some reason it's time
for me to let this go
and the thing is how to find out how to
do it because i wasn't doing very well
on it i was just pounding away at myself
think of this for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time
figure it out
you get all there is
a hobo sleeping under a bridge or on a
park bench
that has no material possessions
none does nothing of any
constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time as the most
productive industrialist in the world
we all get exactly the same amount of
time so it's what we do with the time
that makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun has time management
programs
in fact i made one one time spent a lot
of money on it
and then i found out it was a dumb waste
of time and money do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago
and i was going with him on a speaking
engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever earl nigel said you want to
meet me i was there and i always had
some well-prepared questions and i
remember asking him i said uh how did
you learn how to master time management
you know we're having breakfast i can
still hear his fork hit the plate he's
what the hell are you talking about
he's i've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed
because i merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities and when i
wake up that's what i start working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six
now if i have three that i didn't get
done today that doesn't mean i have nine
for tomorrow like six plus these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up
you give all your conscious attention to
do those things see you cannot manage
time
but you can manage activity
you can manage your activities
make certain that what you're doing
really makes a difference makes certain
that you're spending your time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
there's a process which has made more
people rich than any other single
process of goals achieving
and it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn one hundred thousand dollars
a year then you write how can i earn 100
000
in the next 12 months that's an
open-ended question not how can i earn
it at my job or doing a specific thing
just an open-ended question how can i
earn the amount of money and then you
discipline yourself to write 20 answers
to the question and the 20 answers are
all the different things that you could
think of to earn a hundred thousand
dollars work longer work harder upgrade
my skills you just get a new job take a
part-time opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question
the 20 question method called
mindstorming forces you to dig deep deep
into your mind
where you will find all your answers and
it may be call a person uh read a book
let me give you an example uh we had a
young fellow entrepreneur he got 35
years old he built a successful business
he worked about 10 years to do it and he
for two years wanted to sell his
business so he could take a year off and
travel enjoy his money
and so for two years he just sort of
floundered around like a fish on the
dock wanting to sell his business nobody
uh offered to buy it he suggested it to
people people were not interested and so
on and in this exercise that they put
him through his 20th answer and often
it's the 20th answer that is the
breakthrough
was buy a book on how to sell your own
business
and it just went off like a flash bulb
in his mind at the break he got up as a
downtown hotel got up went down the
street to a major bookstore went and
found he was amazed at the number of
books had been written on how to buy and
sell a business so he bought two or
three books two months later he had
restructured packaged his business sold
it completely satisfactorily and took a
year off
he said but it's just a single idea it
was a breakthrough idea but it was so
simple just get a book on the subject
and you think boy that's pretty obvious
yes but it's the most obvious answers
that we overlook although you cannot
change conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah and it's a lack of
understanding that's causing all our
problems we are the only creature on the
planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
all the little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school and
we've never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch
our physical senses and we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you will you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are
but it really tells us where our mind
was at for a few minutes three weeks ago
got nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority
there is a reason many of the great
women and men of the world the great
history makers the great poets the great
philosophers the great
movement makers rose before the sun
there is a magic in the air at 5 a.m and
that's why the 5am club is so
transformational because it's the time
of greatest quietude and i believe
tranquility is the new luxury on our
planet it is that a time of intimate
creativity because you've just been
rested your brain is fresh there's
there's latest
there's there's very recent cutting edge
science coming out now when you sleep
your brain actually has a mechanism to
wash itself when you wake up in the
morning your willpower is strongest when
you wake up in the morning you've got a
full well of mental focus and we know
that focus in our world is even more
valuable than intelligence and i could
go on and on on the benefits i mean you
get up at 5am you've got the world to
yourself there's no crowds you can think
you can plan you can care for yourself
in a world where so many people are so
depleted and so the fi it the 5 a.m club
really is a game changer and then it's
not just get up at 5am and you know
scratch your stomach or stare up at the
ceiling or look at your phone or look at
especially i believe you can play with
your phone or change the world you don't
get to do both yeah and so uh it the 5am
club method is based on the 20 20 20
formula i'm happy to get into it but
that is tell us what it is that's the
revolutionizer and and it started from
my experience with working with many
billionaires i've i've coached many of
the most successful financiers and
titans of industry for for over two
decades
and one of the things i would run them
through is the way you begin your day
sets up the way you live your day and so
the 20 20 20 formula that the book is
based upon is pretty simple i i go into
great detail in the book but
essentially it's from 5 to 5 20 the
first pocket is move
and i'm a fanatic about neuroscience and
why do you get up and move because
you're going to release serotonin which
is going to make you feel better you're
going to release dopamine which is the
pleasure and inspirational
neurotransmitter you're going to release
norepinephrine which will boost your
focus you'll promote neurogenesis marie
you can actually grow new brain cells
you'll increase your metabolic rate so
the way you beg the way you feel when
you first wake up is not the way you're
going to feel at 5 20. second pocket of
the 20 20 20 formula 20 minutes from 5
20 to 5 40 that's on reflection so a lot
of us are busy but what's the point of
being busy if you're doing the wrong
things
the the billionaires the great creatives
the people of great impact the people
who live beautiful lives are very
intentional they're very deliberate
they're very conscious so for 20 minutes
you write in a journal
you can visualize you can pray you can
meditate you can simply
contemplate
how you're going to live your day who
what you want to stand for during the
day for example and then the final
pocket of the 20 20 20 formula is all
about grow and that's where you you just
read from a biography or a business book
or a philosophy book or
watch marietv well especially watching
tv yeah of course that's the game
changer isn't it and so that's 20
minutes of growing because i think we're
most alive when we are growing yes and
um i believe the leader who learns the
most wins have you ever spent any time
wondering how does everything happen
how does everything happen why does the
night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this
in fact at times it almost drives me
crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud grown and leaves pop
out
and the leaves generally in the spring
are a very deep greeny brown they're not
a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're most
beautiful it is the most beautiful tree
and it's right outside in my studio
i'm sitting here in my desk and
the camera's around me but
out there is that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
every spring they're
greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring
they're always red in the fall and
greeny brown in the spring
think about it
did you ever wonder
why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
i spent some time in the navy in canada
i was down on the east coast for a while
and i was near the bay of fundy do you
know the bay of fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same up around prince george on the west
coast
you go onto a ship
and you might be walking up a plank just
right straight up and you go off the
ship sometimes you're going right down
that ship goes way up in here and it
comes way down very high very low tide
now some place the tide's not very big
they do have a tide but not too high not
too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know
just stayed at a certain length you
wouldn't have to cut it but it would
always look pretty
you know
do you think about this do you know that
everything in this universe happens in
an exact way
an exact way
not by chance
but in an exact way
when john kennedy
the president of the united states
actually asked dr warner von braun
who was the
mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew you didn't have to know how to
do it he knew you had to learn how to do
it but you didn't have to know
to make up your mind you were going to
do it now why did he say that because he
understands the laws
von braun one time said after years of
studying the spectacular mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of god and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise
that we don't even have any difficulty
building spaceship we send people to the
moon and we can time the landing with
the precision of a fraction of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone i see the laws as god's
modus operandi but i'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law
when you and i
get in harmony with the law now we do
that odds are pretty good we should
understand them but when we get in
harmony with the law then i'm going to
tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
[Music]
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them i'm going to
you'll shock yourself with the good you
can do now i've been doing that for the
last 58 years i'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but i
don't understand them as well as i want
to or would like to
but i'm going to study a little more
today you know i get my
trusty book out here
i'll have to talk to you about this part
uh that'll be another talk
study the laws
find out what they write what they're
like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win many of us have issues with
productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burned out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been so i hit a bottom
recently with this productivity overload
and i realized that i had to change my
patterns i had to change my ways i was
then blessed i said a prayer i said i
need some help with my brain fog and i
need some help with my productivity
issue and i that day got an email from
the dr oz show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
doctor dr mike dao and me and mike had
been in touch many years for many years
just because he hadn't been authored we
were published by the same publishers
and mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day i'm like thank you
universe you're giving me exactly what i
need i go on dr oz with mike and i'm
backstage with him and i'm like listen
i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked to
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list i did it i started
to just be very clear about the five
things i was doing in a day i told my
team i made a a list in my base camp
which is where we keep all of our notes
and i made it really clear to myself
these are the only five things i'm doing
throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more i have
been more intuitive i have been more
inspired and i've been more creative you
know the people you surround yourself
with have a phenomenal impact on your
life i think it was carl meneger from
the medicare foundation one time said
environment is more important than
heredity
the people we're surrounded by have a
greater bearing on our life and our
success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often
and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with
have a phenomenal impact on our life and
help make us who we are productivity is
very simple it's a measurement to me i
actually am productive 64 hours a day
and the reason that i'm productive 64
hours a day i call it the power of 64.
is that i focus in on having twice as
many productive hours so most people
work eight productive hours i work 16.
i then focus in on the efficiencies of
those hours to turn the 16 hours to
twice as efficient to 32 hours of
production
and then i look at the statistical
success of what i'm doing to double that
to create 64 hours of production
so when people ask me how do you speak
internationally have your own radio show
on cnbc
run a business have a family of four
kids happy marriage travel do all of
these things well it's easy because i
have 64 hours a day
that i'm doing things
and it may sound silly but i've actually
changed my life by creating and playing
with time let me give you some examples
of what to do i take everything
everything that i do by the minute hour
day month year
and i look at it and i create systems it
may sound a little ocd or any retentive
but it actually works so i took for
example i brushed my teeth lost my teeth
and take listerine every morning
and i took that and i started realizing
that i would days off and forget what
tooth and it took me an average of six
minutes a day
but if i stayed focused in the morning
and that small little thing that i do
every day i can save four minutes
four minutes time seven day was 28
minutes a week times four weeks in a
month was two hours a month times 12
months was 24 hours that i regained the
productivity all because i stay focused
when i brush my teeth lost my teeth and
take a shot of listerine
other things happen i realize that time
is compressed in the morning
so i'm not sure if you can looking at me
realize it i've spent hours of wasted
time in the closet wondering what to
wear
i sit there in the morning no matter how
late i am like oh that or i've lost the
sock or i can't find the right belt
and so i learned this little trick that
i had when i was five years old is i lay
out my clothes at night
but the challenge is when i analyze that
is i didn't want to take away from the
time with my children at night so i
incorporated that with in laying out my
clothes so i took my girls and i let
them lay out my clothes
so they learned colors and sizes
geography where things were bought
finance i did all kinds of type of
things
and now my six-year-old son because i
travel a lot he actually gets excited
when i leave
because he gets to lay out my clothes
and my oldest daughter who's 17 walks by
and tells me oh daddy i i miss laying
out your clothes with you
see how this universal energy
has created itself into efficient
effective statistically successful
things in my life that have nothing to
do with business
it's a matter of putting energy and
creating the habits in performance dr
maxwell mulch wrote a book back around
1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho-cybernetics
it's a phenomenal book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or a reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have done a nose job or
removed a terrible scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate
that we have two images we have the one
that's coming back from the mirror but
we've got an inner image and that inner
self image is literally controlling our
life
you will find people that have very poor
self-image or low self-esteem
they won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life they don't
like themselves
they don't know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago i had very poor self-image
i had low self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're god's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller you'll stand
a little straighter and you know
something you'll enjoy a whole lot more
of life you ever notice that some people
seem to want to hang on to stuff that is
bothering them they're forever talking
about it they don't want to let it go
they've had a a failure at something and
it's dwelling they can't get over it
they just can't get over or somebody
said something nasty to them they don't
want to let it go
do you know what we should do
we should ask ourselves everything that
happens is this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
i don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows
the only thing that can grow is the
thing you give energy to
why would you hold on to anything that's
not serving you now i want you to think
about this i'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because i don't
think i have to i just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you
you're making a terrible error it's
going to cause all kinds of problems you
may blame other people or other things
you may blame the situation
you are the cause of the problem
the man that
told me to pick up this book and read it
ray stanford
he had a saying he used to say to me
bob you're the only problem you'll ever
have and you're the only solution
i think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but i do
understand it
and you know something
i am the only problem i'll ever have and
i am the only solution
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you reject it
do you know the beautiful part about
having an inductive reasoning factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you if you put your shoe on your
shoe is untied
that's a problem that you need to figure
out right and so
at some point the first time maybe that
requires some effort but once you tie
your shoes 100 or 500 times you can
pretty much automate that solution and
do it on autopilot
the same is true for pretty much every
area of life right like if you come home
from work and you're stressed and
exhausted that's a problem that you need
to figure out but there are a variety of
solutions that could solve it you could
play video games for an hour you could
smoke a cigarette you could go for a run
for 20 minutes you could meditate for 10
minutes and any of those solutions uh
whatever one that you come into your
brain starts to fall into that like the
mom who's going to mcdonald's where
she's like i have a problem i need to
feed my kids it's 5 30
and mcdonald's is now a solution and
you're like hey this was easy i should
just automate the solution as much as i
can
and so the key is to try to find a
solution that
delivers the same outcome that solves
the same problem but is also about as
convenient as the previous one otherwise
it's really hard because then you're
just you're trying to opt for a less
convenient solution and the brain
doesn't want to do that it wants to
automate and conserve energy not spend
more energy
that makes a ton of sense you know to
your uh second solution being able to
sit with it i think that's what is so
critical uh and you hear about this in
books like the obstacle is the way in
other books similar that nature where
when you're able to face certain
challenges consistently
and sit with those challenges like an
ice bath or an extended water fast in
those experiences they can be
extrapolated out to all experiences yes
right so like if i can go without food
which is one of the most
primal messages my brain will tell my
body like oh i'm hungry especially
because it's around us 24 7 right and
we're inundated with ads and smells and
all these things
if i can figure out a way to carve out a
four-day block of water only that gives
me strength going into all sorts of
other things that are going to come up
for me intermittent fasting is funny
that way i've been doing it for like
let's see how uh seven or eight years
now and um
there are a lot of solutions that sound
really easy at first but then are
actually hard to implement you know uh
it's like just do do p90x do insanity
and you'll get fit and people like oh
yeah all right i get really motivated
and then it's like they fall off course
after like two weeks or whatever
intermittent fasting is like the
opposite it's hard for people to wrap
their head around it at first like what
do you mean i don't eat breakfast it's
like very difficult for them to get over
that uh because we've been conditioned
that way but then it's actually really
easy to do like you just you don't do
anything you just don't eat you just go
to work like just get started there's
nothing there's no action to take um so
i don't know i need like a phrase for
for things like that but
it is nice that um what i've noticed is
such a small benefit that has nothing to
do with fasting itself is that it does
translate to other areas you know it's
like no i don't need the meal like i was
flying yesterday it's like well i don't
need to eat any of the crap food that's
in the airport you know like yeah oh
they only got [ __ ] peanuts it's fine
i'll be it's gonna be six hours i'll be
fine you know like it's not a big deal
you're not gonna die yeah i remember
thinking the same thing i played
baseball all the way through college and
you know like many sports we had this
kind of like hell week in the beginning
we're you know training conditioning and
everything before the season starts
and um
i remember doing that in the morning we
it started at like 6 a.m and then you
know we got done and i was in class at
like you know nine or something and we
had a test and everybody's freaking out
you see the beautiful truth is you've
already got everything you need inside
you don't have to get it
you don't have to follow the pattern
that our formal educational institutions
teach us
you don't have to read all the books
that's unnecessary
i think madame montessori put it very
well she said we should send a child to
school as if they're an empty cup and we
expect them to fill the cup
geez the truth is the cup's already full
school is to help draw what's already
there
you see you and i are god's highest form
of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will even come close to us
strange things you know you and i are
the only creature on the planet that is
totally disoriented in our environment
all those other little creatures they're
completely at home in their environment
they blend in
we don't
we're totally disoriented and that is
because we have the ability united of
creating our own environment
now think of what that means
that means that you and i can literally
create the life we want
now as i said when i first heard that i
did not believe it
but i knew the man that was giving me
the advice believed it and that man was
raymond douglas stanford one of my very
first mentors i want to talk a little
bit about goals on the line of how do
you lose 37 pounds and write a book i'm
just going to kind of give you that as
an example for 24 years of my adult life
by choice i weighed well over 200 pounds
i say by choice because you see i have
never accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate
and when i choose to eat too much today
i have chosen to weigh
too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals
and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequences are not
going to be good
down the road for 24 years i was going
to lose that weight as a matter of fact
in 24 years i lost several thousand
pounds of weight how many of you already
know exactly what i'm talking about but
it wasn't until i wrote it down
put a date on it
listed the obstacles i had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when i
did that that the goal became a reality
and i lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
i was gonna write a book you know
anybody who's gonna do just a whole lot
of things folks i was gonna write a book
but it wasn't until i got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
now if it sounds like i'm trying to sell
you on heaven goals how many of you are
getting close already how many of you
are becoming convinced right quick like
that you need to have those goals
there's no question about it the
immortal j.c penney many many years ago
said give me a stock clerk with a goal
and i'll give you a man who will make
history but give me a man
without a goal
and i'll give you
a stock clerk
now the interesting thing is golds do
not care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950
a war-torn devastated japan
a nation which had lost an incredibly
high percentage of its young men their
cities were in ruins they had been
bombed out but in 1950 they got together
they meaning industry and government got
together and set a goal the goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world during the 1950s in the
production of textiles
in
1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
said another gold we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of steel now when you
understand there's no iron ore in japan
of any significance there's no coal of
any significance there we're going to be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of steel it seemed like
an absurd goal and yet they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970 the japanese set
another goal they said during the 70s
we'll be the number one nation in the
world in the production of automobiles
they missed it folks
one year it took them until 1980. in
1980 they set another goal and this time
their goal was we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you've got to write it down
what's in it for me
now that's a formula that i have just
given you pure and simple if i want to
do something
i find somebody that's already done it
and then i do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow
i um
i don't read novels
i don't watch movies
um
i'd watch documentaries or things like
that where i can learn
and
i'm only interested in
studying
something that can cause me to become
more of what i'm capable of being
see i think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with our life
and
that's all i want to do
i'm really good at what i do i could
walk by a person in the hall like that i
could tell them exactly what they're
like i could read their energy like a
book
everything goes on the inside shows the
outside see we're gifted with with
faculties of the mind that the average
person knows nothing about you have
intuition the will reason imagination
perception
memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life
we go through school never learn
anything about it like you'll hear
people say they have a bad memory
there's no such thing as a bad memory
everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it
our
imagination your imagination is the most
magnificent he hill said it's the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force the world's ever known i
can use my imagination to project myself
into the future and bring the future
into the present and start living there
you work from the imagination you don't
work to it
you work from it backwards from the
result yeah
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want oprah's advice on how to manifest
your dream check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there let failure be your friend
there are going to be times
of course
where you're going to win a lot a lot of
things are going to go your way